(audience applause)
- So, growing up
in the liquor business
I've always learned
that it's super hard
to compete with alcohol so,
everybody back
there do your thing.
You're not hurting feelings.
So, thank you so
much for having me.
I figured, to be very honest,
especially as I've
been walking around the room
and seeing so
many familiar faces.
I don't think this
group necessarily needs me
to sit up here and pontificate.
Now it's a little dark
and I was hoping to convert this
a little bit into Q&A
so maybe at some point
we'll turn on the lights
or I'll just, I'll roll with it,
but I guess the thing that
I want to really talk about is
the thing that
I've realized that
I've been
spending the last 20 years
of my life on
which is attention.
I think if I synthesize
what I've been up to.
What gives me the
honor of sitting up here
in front of all of you is that
at a very young age
and I mean going
back to lemonade stands.
When I was seven years old
I had a three
lemonade stand franchise
and my friends
worked the lemonade stand
and I would
literally, this is real
and now thinking back
to it it's so, so crazy.
I would literally think
it was fun at seven years old
to walk up and down the
streets of Edison, New Jersey,
sit on the grass and
the corners of streets
and try to figure out
which poles, which trees
were the most
interesting to put signs on
based on watching
human beings drive
and try to follow their eyes
and figure out the spots.
And as sick and fucked
up as that sounds to me,
it's interesting
that that was literally
the blue print for
the rest of my life.
When I did baseball card shows
and I was making $3-4,000
a weekend when I was 12
I now remember, oh it's weird,
I would actually spend the first
4 hours of a baseball card show
walking the entire show,
watching the market,
coming back and
then setting up my table
based on how mine was
different than everybody else
and that ultimately
manifested. Where are we?
That ultimately manifested
somewhere way out there
in Short Hills
Springfield, New Jersey
where my dad had a liquor store
and I got dragged
in when I was 14
and I basically
spent all my days,
15 hours a day,
Saturday and Sunday
and every weekend of my
teenage and high school years
watching how people walked
through that liquor store.
Ultimately, the
internet came around
and in 1996 I launched
one of the first
e-commerce wine
businesses in America
called WineLibrary.com
and I went on to
build that business from a three
to a $60 million business
on the same thesis, which is
where is overpriced attention
and where is
underpriced attention?
When I look around
this room, startups,
consultants, V.C.'s,
you know, business leaders.
I'm curious, because
this is a smart room.
I'm curious if even all
of us are actually stunningly
and grossly underestimating
what's about to happen.
Right, so for example.
Shooting the shit
here a little bit, retail.
Like, retail is
about to get way worse.
Like, like, when like.
It's been interesting
the meetings I'm in, like
if people think what, you know,
what's gonna happen in retail
one little pred...
and this is a prediction.
This is a flat out guess,
but this has been
running through my mind
the last 100 days which is
there's a lot of retailers
that are going out of business
and all of us
look at them and go,
"Yeah that makes sense,
yeah that makes sense."
If we God forbid have a retailer
that seemingly is healthy
go out of business
in the next six months.
It really just collapses
that whole infrastructure.
Everyday, everybody knows here
what's happening with
their behavior, right?
And so, we see this
happen in difference sectors,
but then I was like, okay
retails in a really
scary place because if you care
about big data and analytics
we're starting to get
to that threshold where there's
enough direct to consumer
business happening online that
basically the infrastructure
of leases and bills
really gets scary and
will clearly play out.
It's not going backwards.
You know, every trend
that we're living through
it's not coming back.
You know I'm in a
ton of fucking meetings
with trillion dollar companies
whose new game
plan is tried and true.
Which is always the tale tell to
it's fucking over, right?
Because they're hoping.
And so, retail, cool, next.
A place where I'm
far more confident
of what I'm talking about.
Which is media.
We have
traditional media companies
whether they're
Print, Hearst, Condé
or you know,
Viacom, you know and Fox
like the gig is up.
Like we got another
24 to 36 months,
but when you talk about
$80 billion in TV advertising,
like, that's gonna play out,
like it over,
like, O.T.T. is real.
Facebook comes out with it's
O.T.T. product in a month.
You know, and the same
way that you didn't think
you'd watch a Netflix
until there was House of Cards.
You don't think
you're gonna watch a sitcom
or show on Facebook
until something comes out
that you are gonna watch.
And so today with Alexa
when you look at the
gangster level in which Facebook
and Amazon are innovating.
Not giving a fuck about wall
street and short term ROI
and investing for the long term.
It's just very clear to
everybody smart in here.
What I'm curious
about though is are we just
underestimating the whole thing.
Is the internet now
hitting real maturity
22, 23 years into
consumer internet.
1995, Windows 95
normal people went on.
I know there's
some nerds in here,
but normal people
went on around that time.
(audience laughter)
And so are we just
hitting that crescendo moment?
Because you've
got incredible trends.
When I think about CPG brands
and the absolute fascination
I have over the next decade
of watching the
biggest brands in the world:
Proctor, Unilever,
J&J, Coca-Cola, Pepsi.
Go through channel
conflict wars with Walmart
and Costco and Target.
DTC is putting so much pressure.
The internet is the middle man.
And bookstores
and black car services
just got caught first.
And so everything's coming.
I have sat in my
office on the 25th floor
of this beautiful
building in the last 100 days
and have sat down with
founders who have started
direct to consumer fashion
brands that have gone from zero
to between
$3 and 10 million in revenue
in one year on the
back of having pretty people
on Instagram post about it.
- [Woman] mmhmm.
- When you start understanding
and this is my
macro for all of us.
I think everybody here
needs to start understanding
that every incumbent
is not gonna lose
to another incumbent.
They're losing by
the death of 1,000 cuts.
Right?
It's not that Ralph Lauren
which is going through
what it's going through.
It's not that LVMH or Coach is
putting them out of business.
It's that there's 4,000
brands that are gonna do
$4 million in revenue next year.
And that shit adds up.
And that's just
happening everywhere
and we're living
through the long tail.
It's even happening in
the most innovative places.
There's a lot of people
here that have not quantified
how underpriced
influencer marketing is yet.
Yet, even in that world,
disruption has come
because the long
tail influencers of
25 to 50,000 followers
are starting to disrupt
the people that are overpriced
with a million followers.
I mean, it's happening so fast.
I'm watching very
smart people jump into things
three years after
it actually happened
with four years ago talk,
and that creates
enormous disruption.
And so I guess, the
one thing that I would say
again, seeing a lot of
faces that I know here.
So we've got real top to bottom,
CEOs of billion dollar companies
people that are
starting startups.
I think we really need
to calibrate several things
which is there's an
obnoxious amount of opportunity
because people are under
valuing where the attention is.
The attention is
in the cell phone.
Our cell phone is the
remote control of our lives.
Period. End of story.
There's nothing
remotely close to as important
as the cell phone and
when you start understanding
that over 50% of the
time spent on the cell phone
is spent on
seven to 10 core apps
which are social networks
and throw in YouTube in there
or whatever you want to call it.
You're talking about
more than half of the time
we spend on cell phones
on things called Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram,
Snapchat, and YouTube
and all of the sudden
social media goes away
from being a slang
term that people think
is an after
thought or a sprinkle
and it starts becoming the
foundation of communication
in our society.
And so I implore
and one of the things
that I'm very fascinated by
so for example, I think
Facebook videos are the great
underpriced opportunity
to change your business.
So if I'm a SaaS B2B
business in this room
doing $500 million in revenue
instead of getting
booths at trade shows
and buying ads in B2B magazines,
I know that I could
run a video on Facebook
that's two minutes
and 18 seconds long
and I can target
employees of any company I want
and the copy and the opening
line of the video could be
does your CIO know?
And I know that that
CIO will then get 700 people
or 17 people or she will get
14 people sending that video,
and that becomes a
gateway to business development.
People are just
not practitioners.
This room is filled with people
who have a whole lot of
things to say about stuff,
but have never actually done it.
There's a lot of opinions here
on buying Snapchat filters
in the open marketplace.
(crowd laughs)
There's a lot of opinions here.
You like that? It's true.
And I say it because
I do it in every other thing
that I don't know what the fuck
I'm talking about in, right?
I've got opinions on everything.
But what's been fascinating
is that people got opinions
on what's actually happening,
but they're not practitioners.
We have a massive disconnect
between headline reading
and practitionership
in the modern day
of running
businesses and marketing.
And that is an enormous
arbitrage of opportunity
and it's also the preview
to a whole lot of carnage.
And so, I don't know.
I think as somebody who's
most comfortable in chaos,
think this is gonna be the best.
I desperately want
Wall Street to melt,
I want, I'm so tired of
all these peacetime generals,
these CEOs that
have been navigating
the last seven
years of good times.
I think we need a
massive correction,
I would prefer it.
And in that correction there
will be enormous opportunity
because the biggest
brains in the world,
overhead and infrastructure,
is based on a world
that doesn't exist anymore.
And you know what's funny?
The 13-15 faces that I'm able to
actually see with the lighting,
you all know.
(audience laughter)
I can see it.
You all know.
I'm not so smart,
I'm just saying it.
And I'm saying it,
not because I'm noble,
but because my
economics are tied up in it.
And so, one thing I would tell
this extremely smart group,
is the most
fascinating thing about the last
20 years of my career,
is that people say
shit they don't believe,
because of short-term economics,
which eliminate all their
long-term
economic opportunities.
And so this group,
needs to debate that.
Because this room
is filled with that,
and in that is
outrageous opportunity.
So if you work somewhere,
and you believe something else,
I highly recommend
you put it on the record
'cause everybody in
that room will remember,
when shit hits the fan,
and the people that are
historically right, win.
And that is going
to be very important
for your actual livelihood.
Right now, you
may be pandering to
what's good for your livelihood,
for your bonus right now,
but when shit hits
the fan, you get negated,
and debt, it's a detriment for
being historically incorrect.
So, I would implore everybody
to look at the macro math.
To understand
what's really going on.
We live in a world Kylie Jenner
got paid 1.3 million dollars
last week, to post one picture
on Instagram and Snapchat.
And guess what, it
was a good fucking deal.
It was.
And so, I think people
are holding on to a reality
that doesn't exist anymore, so,
I'm pumped.
(audience laughter)
And I hope you are
too, because if you are,
that means that you
haven't bought that,
you know, people love to make,
I was with a client, CMO, and
she was razzing on retail,
and I was like, but
you're doing the same thing
with your
corporate career in here.
Your infrastructure,
your golden handcuffs,
are their leases.
So I dunno, I think
it's an interesting time,
and I really
appreciate your attention.
I'd love to do a little
Q&A if anybody's interested
so, thanks for having me.
(audience applause and cheers)
Q&A?
Anybody have any questions?
About anything, randomly?
Yeah.
- [Man] You said
on the, thank you sir,
- Shh!
- [Man] You said on the
cell phones, with the issue,
50 percent plus people are,
- Yes, yes.
- [Man] Spending all of
their time on cell phones
seven to ten apps.
- Yes.
- I don't wanna say
that those apps are, kind of,
time-wasting, that
might not be the word,
but what happens,
what are the next,
seven to ten big apps,
and what are
people going to be doing?
- I have,
so, I have no fucking idea.
(audience laughter)
You know, I get a lot of
credit cause I was an early
investor in
Facebook and Twitter and
Snapchat and these things,
but they've already,
they already made it.
The only thing I do is,
I'm a practitioner,
I think it's a good idea
to wake up in the morning
and look at the top 200 apps
in the app store or at Appway
and look at data, and download
the app and play with it.
I'm not guessing, these
things have already made it,
I'm just moving
a little bit faster
than the rest of
the market, right?
Now, I don't think
they're time-wasters,
because I think escapism is
a core need for human beings.
So, whether it's
reading a book, or watching TV,
I watch grown men run
into each other, you know?
'Cause I love football,
but that's my escapism
from my, right?
So, I don't judge
people doing that thing.
You know what's funny?
I don't care, right?
I think way too
many people here debate
and have a
romantic point of view
of how they
want the world to be,
I just react to the way
the world is actually acting.
Who am I to judge?
I was told as a kid,
playing video games
was a waste of time.
I'm watching kids making
$15 million a year
play eSports.
(audience laughter)
Shit changes, right?
And so, I think that,
I'm not sure,
but what i will say is this,
the only great arbitrage
to the internet itself,
that is even out there, is VR.
But, as I was
talking to somebody earlier,
I believe that
consumer VR is quite far away.
To me, I react to reality,
nobody here
knows somebody that's
spending three
hours a day on VR.
Everybody here is spending seven
hours a day on their phone.
When you start
adding up your time on the,
we're already, in
theory, living in VR.
We're living through our phone.
Do you know how many people
here went hiking this weekend,
to take the selfie,
to PR themselves,
to the fucking friends?
(audience laughter)
There is consumer
behavior that is happening,
that we are grossly
underestimating to why,
and things of that nature,
so I don't know, but
what I will tell you is
I day trade attention.
My life, until I die, will be
why does slime matter
to eight year olds, right?
Why did spinners happen,
why do people care
about Logic and Russ,
why are they spending
so much time on Instagram,
and I don't judge,
I just react and sell.
Maybe pass her one, please?
The lady right there.
How are you?
- Hi, great.
So I know you have
this thing with bots now,
so what are some
of your favorite bots
that you're chatting with?
- [Gary] So I am, you
know the funny part is,
I am obsessed with that space,
but I'm more paying atten--
you know it's funny,
like for example,
I don't consume content.
I'm not necessarily
using a bunch of bots that I'm
looking at what's going on with,
meet courts, and Reddit,
and some media companies,
and then, and then retailers,
there's a small yogurt
startup that's got a real
great messenger bot
that's doing extremely well.
But what's really
weird about the way I roll,
I don't spend much
time doing any of this shit,
I spend all my
time watching you do it.
- [Woman] Would
you chat with my robot?
- Would I?
Sure.
- [Woman] There's
a robot that just says
bro back to everything you said.
- I'm a little bit more into,
(laughing)
I'm in.
(audience laughter)
Any other questions?
Yeah, let's bring it over here.
Here, I'll switch with you,
you can give me that one.
- [Sid] Hi, it's Sid, so,
- [Gary] Shh, guys.
- I will be presenting
the dying vertical of retail,
as you painted,
I work for Under Armor.
- [Gary] Listen, I have a
50,000 square foot wine store
right across the
river, I'm in it too.
- [Sid] So,
we'll work it together.
- Yeah, we'll figure it out.
- [Sid] But so, for a
brand like Under Armor,
we've traditionally had success
doubling down on
sporting assets,
and endorsements.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And yeah, it's
worked well for us,
we've had the (inaudible)
so, if you think about the
long tail, influencer network
talked about, you could probably
imagine brands
like (inaudible), right?
- [Gary] I'm super aware of your
business, we've done some stuff.
To me it's interesting right,
in a world where you have
Cam Newton and Jordan,
and Brady and Steph,
you also are in a
place where you're not
fully even supporting
people like Julio Jones
'cause you have a long
tail, and yet there's people
even further down the long tail,
that you have,
I think that, it's
a sports endorsement,
and fame arbitrage,
guys, fame is the ultimate
arbitrage in our society.
So it's a great business model,
I think that, most of
your athletes at this point
are locked into contracts
that grossly overpay them
on their influence.
Because we locked them in,
in a world that has shifted.
So it's going to be
really interesting to see what
you and your two or
three competitors are gonna do.
Obviously you've seen
your direct competitors
in a shoe space go in
a different direction and
go towards music, you know,
it's one thing for
Yeezys to happen,
it's another thing to watch what
Rihanna's doing with Puma,
like this is real.
Right, and then, back to what
I was talking about earlier,
there's a ton of little
micro things going on under,
you know, collaborations,
what Beep is doing,
and others, and so,
it's interesting,
I think Under Armour
has a very traditional
Nike-like blueprint,
I really do from afar,
I think that it'll be,
I'm gonna tell
you one of the things
that I'm most excited
about, as a fan of business,
is to actually
see what you guys do
over the next
two or three years.
'Cause I think
there's opportunities
for you to innovate,
out of necessity.
- [Sid] Yeah, no, I
think that's right,
I think it just sort of
goes back to the fact that
the space you're talking
about, where do you invest,
where do you go,
and I figure ultimately
everything's a prioritization,
I think the
decision you have to make,
based on what's most important.
- [Gary] But that's when you
overspend on things
in an old world,
so for me, I'd much
rather allocate $300,000
in production and
distribution around Julio Jones
in an Atlanta area,
than spend the
ridiculous production value
to launch a Steph Curry shoe,
doing a commercial
during the NBA playoffs.
Not that you're right
and I'm wrong, or vice versa,
I just think that's
how it's gonna play out.
- [Sid] Yeah,
looking forward to that.
- Yeah.
- [Sid] Thanks.
- Done?
Thank you guys.
(audience cheers and applause)
(jazzy music)